Ira Glass：Joe Franklin?
Joe Franklin：I'm ready.
Joe Franklin：我准备好了。
Ira Glass：It's Ira Glass here.
Ira Glass：我是Ira Glass。
Joe Franklin：Oh, you're the emcee on the show, Ira.
Joe Franklin：噢，你是节目的主持人，Ira。
Ira Glass：I am the emcee on the show. Yes.
Ira Glass：我是节目的主持人。是的。
Joe Franklin：Oh great. Ira? I-R-A, Ira?
Joe Franklin：太好了。Ira？I-R-A，Ira吗？
Ira Glass：Ira, I-R-A.
Ira Glass：Ira，I-R-A。
Joe Franklin：Oh, great. Now hold on one second, Ira. Don't go away. Hello? [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Call me after 3 o'clock. I have great news for you. Ira.
Joe Franklin：噢，太好了。现在等一下，Ira。别走开。喂？[听不清]。3点以后打给我。我有个好消息要告诉你。Ira。
Ira Glass：Yes.
Ira Glass：是的。
Joe Franklin：So listen, Tony. If the phone rings, take it in the back. And then come out and tell me who it is. Just say, Joe's being with a camera crew. Just for about 10 minutes. We'll do about five minutes, 10 minutes, right, Ira?
Joe Franklin：听着，Tony。如果电话响了，去后面接。然后出来告诉我那是谁。就说，Joe正在录影。只要大约10分钟。我们大概做五分钟，10分钟，对吧，Ira？
Ira Glass：That's right.
Ira Glass：没错。
Ira Glass：Well, one great thing about starting a new show is utter anonymity. Nobody really knows what to expect from you. This interviewee did not know us from Adam.
Ira Glass：嗯，开启一个新节目的一大好处就是完全默默无闻。没人真正知道该对你抱有什么期待。这位受访者根本不认识我们。
Ira Glass：OK, we're what? About a minute. We're one minute five into the new show. Right now, it is stretching in front of us, a perfect future yet to be fulfilled. An uncharted little world. A little baby coming into the world, no little scars on it or anything.
Ira Glass：好了，我们现在是怎样？大概一分钟。新节目开始一分零五秒了。现在，它在我们面前延展开来，是一个尚未实现的完美未来。一个未知的微小世界。一个刚来到这个世界的小婴儿，身上还没有任何伤疤之类的东西。
Ira Glass：Nobody hearing my words right now is thinking, "Oh, man, remember that show, back when it used to be good? That show, I never missed that show back in the old days, back in the first couple years before it got so-called popular. Back when it was still good."
Ira Glass：现在听到我说话的人，没有人在想：“噢，伙计，还记得那个节目吗，在它还不错的时候？那个节目，在过去的日子里，在它变得所谓流行起来的头几年之前，我从来没错过那个节目。在它还不错的时候。”
Ira Glass：No, actually, I think that force, that human desire to say that is so strong, to say that "I was there back when that show was good," that force is so strong, it is so basic to who we are as people that I know-- OK, what are we? We are two minutes into the program-- I know that somewhere out there, one or two of you are saying, "Oh, sure. I used to listen to that show back in the first 30 seconds, back when it used to be really good. Remember back when they used to do all that crazy stuff? When they had that guy on the phone? Remember back then?"
Ira Glass：不，实际上，我认为那种力量，那种人类想要说出那句话的渴望是如此强烈，那种想要说“在那个节目还不错的时候，我就已经在那里了”的渴望，这种力量如此强大，它是我们作为人类的基本属性，所以我知道——好吧，我们现在是多少？节目开始两分钟了——我知道在外面某个地方，你们中的一两个正在说：“噢，当然了。我过去常听那个节目，在最初的那30秒，在它真正还不错的时候。还记得他们过去做那些疯狂事情的时候吗？当他们让那个人打电话来的时候？还记得那时候吗？”
Ira Glass：Well, from WBEZ, in the glorious city of Chicago, Illinois. The name of this show is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm your emcee. I'm your emcee, Ira Glass.
Ira Glass：好吧，来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥市，荣耀的WBEZ广播电台。这个节目的名字叫《Your Radio Playhouse》。我是你们的主持人。我是你们的主持人，Ira Glass。
Ira Glass：OK, the idea of this show, this new little show, is stories, some by journalists and documentary producers, like myself, some just regular people telling their own little stories, some by artists, and writers, and performers of all different kinds. And the idea is we're going to bring you stuff you're not going to find anywhere else. And there is also going to be music.
Ira Glass：好的，这个节目，这个新节目的构思是故事，有些来自记者和纪录片制作人，比如我自己，有些只是普通人讲述他们自己的小故事，有些来自艺术家、作家以及各种各样的表演者。我们的构思是，我们将为你带来你在其他任何地方都找不到的内容。而且还会有音乐。
Ira Glass：And tonight's show, we thought that we would have a theme. Tonight's show is going to be New Beginnings. And to kick things off, I called the man who's had, as best as anybody can tell, the longest running program in the history of television. His name is Joe Franklin, and his program ran for 43 years on local television in New York. And he claims that he invented the talk show format. And I called him to get some advice on how to create a long-running, healthy program.
Ira Glass：今晚的节目，我们想设定一个主题。今晚的主题是“新的开始”。为了拉开序幕，我打电话给了一个人，据大家所知，他拥有电视史上播放时间最长的节目。他的名字叫Joe Franklin，他的节目在纽约当地电视台播放了43年。他声称是他发明了脱口秀节目形式。我打电话给他，是为了请教如何创办一个长盛不衰、健康发展的节目。
Joe Franklin：I've been called in many times to give a sort of a Dean, the elder statesman, even though I'm still a young kid. But I've been called in to give this kind of advice to new kids on the block. Conan O'Brien had me on his first show. And people like that. There's no guidance. It's a matter of paying attention.
Joe Franklin：我曾多次被请去担任某种导师，作为资深政治家，尽管我依然是个年轻的孩子。但我曾被请去给这些新秀提供此类建议。Conan O'Brien在他的第一个节目中就邀请过我。还有类似那样的人。这没有什么指南。关键在于专注。
Joe Franklin：Your voice, I've heard so much about the sparkle, about the energy in your voice. The voice, on radio especially, is everything. And when the guest is sitting with you, you've got to look into his eyes. Many times, you get an author on there who's begrudgingly sitting there. He'd rather be home in his ivory tower.
Joe Franklin：你的声音，我听过很多关于你声音中闪光点和活力的评价。在广播中，声音尤其是一切。当嘉宾和你坐在一起时，你必须注视他的眼睛。很多时候，你会遇到一位心不甘情不愿坐在那里的作者。他宁愿待在自己象牙塔里的家中。
Joe Franklin：And above all, get the plug fast. Otherwise, he's worried you're not going to make the plug for the book. And I created a line, Ira, that's been picked up by George Burns. I always said, the main ingredient for longevity in the talk show field, where the mortality rate is so staggering, the main ingredient is sincerity. And once you learn to fake that, then you got it made. I made that up. And I just played it by ear. I was a natural born talker, I guess.
Joe Franklin：最重要的是，快点打广告。否则，他会担心你没法为书做宣传。Ira，我创造了一句被George Burns引用的话。我总是说，在谈话节目这个死亡率高得惊人的领域，长久生存的主要秘诀就是真诚。一旦你学会了伪造真诚，你就成功了。那是我编出来的。我只是随性而发。我想我天生就是一个健谈的人。
Ira Glass：So let me just summarize what I'm getting from you. You're saying you should just pay attention, look people in the eye, be sincere when I'm on the air, get in the plug early.
Ira Glass：让我总结一下我从你那听到的。你是说我应该专注，直视人们的眼睛，在直播时表现得真诚，并且尽早打广告。
Joe Franklin：That's the key. And don't look in their nose or their belly button. Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything. And as I say, it's a lot of fun.
Joe Franklin：那是关键。不要盯着他们的鼻子或肚脐。要直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。而且正如我所说，这很有趣。
Joe Franklin：And I never called anybody in my life to come on to my show. And I'm sure that they'll be coming to you too. I heard about you, and I called you and wanted to wish you good look, Ira. Imagine the thrill of John F. Kennedy walking into my studio. Richard Nixon. Ronald Reagan, five times. And Bing Crosby.
Joe Franklin：我这辈子从没打过电话请任何人来参加我的节目。我相信他们也会主动来找你。我听说过你，所以我打电话给你，想祝你好运，Ira。想象一下John F. Kennedy走进我的演播室是多么激动人心。还有Richard Nixon，Ronald Reagan（五次），以及Bing Crosby。
Joe Franklin：And I've got a major book out right now, by the way, Ira, called Up Late with Joe Franklin from Simon & Schuster. And if you find a copy in the store--
Joe Franklin：顺便说一下，Ira，我刚出了一本大书，由Simon & Schuster出版，书名叫《Up Late with Joe Franklin》。如果你在店里看到的话——
Ira Glass：You see now, I guess I've sort of messed that one up, because I didn't let you get in your plug early.
Ira Glass：你看，我想我把那件事搞砸了，因为我没让你早点打广告。
Joe Franklin：See, that is my fault. I got it in toward the bitter end. It's like Duke Ellington. He always used to have his dessert at the beginning of the meal. Duke Ellington said, because he would never have no room for it at the end. So he had his dessert at the beginning. Who is it? Well, no, good news, 6 o'clock.
Joe Franklin：看，那是我的错。我是在最后关头才插进去的。就像Duke Ellington。他总是喜欢在吃正餐前先吃甜点。Duke Ellington说，因为他怕到最后就没胃口了。所以他先吃甜点。是谁？好吧，不，6点钟有新闻。
Ira Glass：Well, Joe Franklin, thank you very much for being with us on our premier show.
Ira Glass：好吧，Joe Franklin，非常感谢你参加我们的首播节目。
Joe Franklin：Ira, I'm going to be a listener and a fan. And let's always be in touch.
Joe Franklin：Ira，我会成为你的听众和粉丝的。让我们保持联系。
Joe Franklin：[MUSIC - "DESTINATION MOON" BY DINAH WASHINGTON]
Joe Franklin：[音乐 - DINAH WASHINGTON的“DESTINATION MOON”]
Ira Glass：All right, Your Radio Playhouse. All right. I'm making eye contact with you right-- wait, how does Joe put it? Wait a second.
Ira Glass：好的，Your Radio Playhouse。好的。我正在和你进行眼神交流——等等，Joe是怎么说的？等一下。
Joe Franklin：Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
Joe Franklin：直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
Ira Glass：I am making eye contact with you right now. That is just how much I have already learned. OK, so the thing about new beginnings is that there are the ones that we actually undertake and then there are the ones that we just wish for. And the ones that we wish for pretty much outnumber the ones that we really undertake.
Ira Glass：我现在正在和你进行眼神交流。这就是我已经学到的东西。好的，关于新的开始，有些是我们真正着手去做的，有些是我们只是希望发生的。我们希望发生的远比我们真正去做的要多得多。
Ira Glass：Well, Kevin Kelly spent most of his twenties wandering around Asia. He was basically wandering around as a freelance photographer. And he found himself photographing a lot of religious ceremonies and drawn to religious ceremonies of all sorts. And he says that he was really confused about what he believed. And he was the kind of person who had always dreamt about a new beginning, where he wouldn't struggle with these questions.
Ira Glass：Kevin Kelly在他二十多岁的大部分时间里都在亚洲游历。他基本上是以自由摄影师的身份四处流浪。他发现自己拍摄了很多宗教仪式，并被各种宗教仪式所吸引。他说他对自己信仰什么感到非常困惑。他曾是那种一直梦想着一个新开始的人，在那样的开始里，他不必再去纠结这些问题。
Kevin Kelly：I would get twisted and caught up. And these things were in the background, consuming me. And actually, I found that I could think about little else for many, many months, that behind all that I was doing, there was always this unresolved question of was God real. And if he was real, then how could we ignore him? And if we were trying to not ignore him, what would we do? And if he was real, then what about these other things that people said about God?
Kevin Kelly：我会变得纠结和深陷其中。这些事情一直藏在心底，吞噬着我。实际上，我发现好几个月来我几乎想不出别的事情，在我所做的一切背后，始终有一个未解的疑问：上帝是真的吗？如果他是真的，那我们怎么能忽视他？如果我们努力不去忽视他，我们该怎么做？如果他是真的，那人们关于上帝说的其他事情又是怎么回事呢？
Ira Glass：We will not attempt to answer these questions, by the way, in this hour. I just want to just give you a sense of scope here, just modest scope. But what we want to talk about is what happened to Kevin Kelly. What happened is that at the age of 27, all of this changed when he came into Jerusalem on the eve of Easter and Passover. It was the same weekend. And flocks of people are coming into the city.
Ira Glass：顺便说一下，在这个小时里，我们不会试图回答这些问题。我只是想让你了解一下范围，仅仅是适度的范围。但我们想谈论的是Kevin Kelly发生了什么。发生的事情是，在他27岁那年，当他在复活节和逾越节前夕来到耶路撒冷时，这一切都改变了。那是同一个周末。成群结队的人涌入这座城市。
Kevin Kelly：So I entered Jerusalem on Easter with a simple expectation that I was going to photograph another religious ceremony, another religious festival. And then, for various reasons, I got locked out of my hostel room. They had a curfew. And I didn't make it back in time. And I was in quite a fix because I was a stranger in this very strange town. When it happened, I didn't have enough money to stay elsewhere, nor did I even have knowledge of where to go.
Kevin Kelly：所以我带着一个简单的期望进入了耶路撒冷，那就是去拍摄另一个宗教仪式，另一个宗教节日。然后，由于各种原因，我被锁在了旅舍房间外。他们有宵禁。我没能及时赶回来。我陷入了困境，因为我是这个陌生城镇里的陌生人。当事情发生时，我既没有足够的钱去别处住，也不知道该去哪里。
Kevin Kelly：So I wandered the Old Town of Jerusalem at night, which had been shuttered up and was like a time machine. It was as if I had been transported back to the 15th century, because all the souvenir vendors were gone, and what was left were the labyrinthian paths of cobbled passageways. And I wandered around for a number of hours, and it was getting colder. Eventually, I found myself at the one place that was still open, which was some of the churches. And particularly, after wandering around until about 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning, I finally settled into the Church of the Holy Scepter, which is called and viewed as the church built over the mound where Jesus Christ was crucified.
Kevin Kelly：于是我在夜晚游荡在耶路撒冷的老城，那里大门紧闭，就像一台时间机器。仿佛我被带回了15世纪，因为所有的纪念品小贩都不见了，剩下的只有迷宫般的鹅卵石小巷。我徘徊了几个小时，天气越来越冷。最终，我发现自己来到了唯一还开放的地方，也就是一些教堂。特别是，在凌晨2点或3点左右游荡后，我最终在圣墓教堂安顿下来，这里被认为是建在耶稣基督被钉十字架的土丘上的教堂。
Kevin Kelly：And I was getting very tired. And there weren't many people around. And so eventually, I laid myself out on about the only flat area that was left, which was this marble slab underneath some pendants that had incense on them. And this was presumably the slab that commemorated the exact positioning of the crosses. So I slept there. I slept on the crucifixion spot on that night because it was the only place-- they had no place in the inn.
Kevin Kelly：我非常累了。周围没有多少人。于是，我最终躺在了仅存的一块平地上，那是一块放在有香炉的吊饰下方的在大理石板。这大概就是纪念十字架确切位置的石板。所以我睡在那里。那天晚上我睡在受难地点，因为那是唯一的地方——旅馆里已经没有房间了。
Kevin Kelly：I slept there until early morning, when the activity started to increase, and people started coming in. And I went out and followed the crowd where it was going when they were going out to the tombs area in Jerusalem. And I went out. And there were some folding chairs set up in front of this tomb area. And as the sun was coming up on that Easter morning, I was staring at empty tombs. And for a reason that I can not comprehend, as I sat on that chair contemplating this view of the early sun morning coming into the empty tombs, all that I had been wrestling with for the past many, many years in thinking about religion sort of became resolved in my mind. And at that very moment, I believed that Jesus Christ had, indeed, risen from those tombs.
Kevin Kelly：我睡到清晨，直到活动开始增多，人们开始涌入。我走出去，跟着人群前往耶路撒冷的墓地。我走了出去。在墓地前架设了一些折叠椅。当复活节早晨的太阳升起时，我盯着空荡荡的坟墓。出于一种我无法理解的原因，当我坐在椅子上凝视着清晨的阳光照进空墓的景色时，我过去多年来在宗教思考上一直纠结的所有问题，在我的脑海中似乎都得到了解决。就在那一刻，我相信耶稣基督确实从那些坟墓中复活了。
Kevin Kelly：In an instant, the tension of trying to figure things out was resolved, because now, suddenly, everything was figured out. It was as if you had been working on a problem for a long time and suddenly the answer was there. And it was very clear that was the answer. And although there were many things that were still not clear to you, you were very certain that you were on the right path.
Kevin Kelly：那一瞬间，试图弄明白这一切的紧张感烟消云散了，因为现在，一切突然都已明了。就像你一直致力于解决一个难题，答案突然就出现在眼前。而且很清楚，那就是答案。虽然还有许多事情你仍然看不透，但你非常确定自己走在正确的道路上。
Kevin Kelly：Having that realization that I believe that Jesus Christ had actually risen from those tombs did not settle 1,001 other things about what one was supposed to do with that, what I was supposed to do with that. Did that mean I was supposed to be a monk? Did that mean I was supposed to be an evangelist?
Kevin Kelly：意识到我相信耶稣基督真的从墓穴中复活了，并没有解决关于一个人该用这个事实做什么、我该用它做什么的一千零一个其他问题。这是否意味着我应该成为一名僧侣？还是意味着我应该成为一名传教士？
Kevin Kelly：Did that mean that I had to immediately renounce all that I had, and get into sackcloths and ashes, and march out into the desert? All that was left unopened. And that is, in fact, what occupied my mind as I went back to my hostel to lay down and think about. Because I had no clue what it really meant to me ultimately, and that's what I was pondering when I was laying there napping. And I wouldn't say it was a voice, but there was an idea that came into my mind that just would not go away, and that was that I should live as if I would die in six months, that I should really, truly live. And that I could not tell for certain whether I would really die, but that either way, I should live as if I was going to die. And so that was the assignment.
Kevin Kelly：这是否意味着我必须立即放弃所有财产，披上麻布，撒上灰烬，走进沙漠？所有这些问题都悬而未决。事实上，当我回到旅舍躺下思考时，脑子里想的正是这些。因为我根本不知道这对我的最终意义是什么，而我躺着小憩时思考的正是这些。我不会说那是一个声音，但确实有一个念头出现在我脑海中，挥之不去，那就是我应该像只剩下六个月生命一样去生活，我应该真正地、实在地生活。我无法确定自己是否真的会死，但无论如何，我都应该像快要死了一样去生活。这就是我的任务。
Kevin Kelly：I'm a pretty rational person. I'm pretty logical. And after thinking the thought that I should live as if I was going to die in six months, the first thought that comes to my head was, "Well, that's pretty silly. I have no evidence whatsoever. I could live like I'm going to die in six months and not die at all. It would just be an interesting exercise."
Kevin Kelly：我是一个相当理性、相当讲逻辑的人。在想到“我应该像只剩下六个月生命一样去生活”这个念头后，我脑海中出现的第一个想法是：“好吧，这太傻了。我没有任何证据。我可能过着像只剩六个月生命的日子，结果却根本没死。那不过是一场有趣的演习罢了。”
Kevin Kelly：But at the same time, it was equally probable that I might die in six months. It happened all the time. There was no guarantee that I wouldn't die. And so fairly quickly, I decided that I could not settle that issue of whether I would really die or not, or just think that I was going to die in six months, and that, in either case, the important thing was to live as if I really believed that I was going to die in six months, which is what I set out to do.
Kevin Kelly：但与此同时，我也同样有可能在六个月内死去。这种事随时都在发生。没有任何保证我不会死。所以，我很快决定，我无法解决“我是否真的会死”或者“只是假设自己要死”这个问题，无论哪种情况，重要的是像我真的相信自己只有六个月生命那样去生活，而这就是我开始做的事情。
Kevin Kelly：The next couple days, I had the joyous experience of saying to myself, "OK, what do I do for six months if I have only six months to live?" And the answers to that surprised me as much as the assignment, because after thinking that through and contemplating it, the conclusion that I came to was that what I wanted to do for six months was to go home and be ordinary, to go back to my parents, to help them take out the trash, and trim the hedges, and move furniture around, and to be with them. And I was really shocked by that, because I thought that with six months to live, I would climb Mount Everest, or I would go scuba diving to the depths of the ocean, or get in a speedboat and see how fast I could go. But instead, I wanted to go back home and be with my family for that time.
Kevin Kelly：接下来的几天，我有一种快乐的体验，我对自己说：“好吧，如果我只剩下六个月的时间，我该做什么？”答案令我惊讶，就像这个任务本身一样。因为在深思熟虑之后，我得出的结论是，我想做的就是回家，过平凡的生活，回到父母身边，帮他们倒垃圾、修剪树篱、搬动家具，陪伴他们。我对此感到非常震惊，因为我原以为，如果只剩下六个月的生命，我会去攀登珠穆朗玛峰，去深海潜水，或者坐上快艇去体验风驰电掣的速度。但相反，我只想回家，在那段时间里和家人在一起。
Kevin Kelly：I, of course, did not tell anybody my crazy idea. This is, in fact, the first time I'm really talking about it publicly. Because it's a very scary and alarming idea. And I never told anybody why I was coming home.
Kevin Kelly：当然，我没有告诉任何人我这个疯狂的想法。事实上，这是我第一次真正公开谈论它。因为它是一个非常可怕和令人不安的想法。我从未告诉任何人我为什么要回家。
Kevin Kelly：I got back to where my parents live in New Jersey, and things were unbelievably ordinary. And yet, I found myself relishing the ordinariness and finding it in some ways as exotic as anything that I had traveled to see. I helped around the house. I dug up shrubs. I worked on a deck. I moved furniture, washed dishes.
Kevin Kelly：我回到了父母居住的新泽西州，一切都平凡得难以置信。然而，我发现自己非常享受这种平凡，甚至在某些方面觉得它和我曾旅行去过的地方一样充满异国情调。我帮着做家务，挖灌木，修露台，搬家具，洗碗。
Kevin Kelly：And I was intending to spend my last remaining six months at home getting to know my parents better and myself, hopefully. But about three months into that, my travel urges, I guess, got the better of me. And what I was most concerned about was I wanted to see my brothers and sisters. I had four brothers and sisters. And they were scattered all across the country. And so I felt very strongly that I wanted to see them before I died. And I got the idea that the way to see them was to ride my bicycle across the country and visit them on bicycle.
Kevin Kelly：我本来打算在家里度过剩下的六个月，希望能更好地了解我的父母，也了解我自己。但大约过了三个月，我的旅行欲望似乎又占了上风。我最关心的是我想见我的兄弟姐妹。我有四个兄弟姐妹，他们分散在全国各地。所以我强烈地感到，我希望在死前见到他们。于是我想到，见到他们的方式就是骑自行车横跨全国，去拜访他们。
Kevin Kelly：But before I did that, I made up a will to dispose of the little things that I had. And I had some money left over. And one of the things I did with that money was I went to the bank and got some cashier's checks for $500 and $1,000. And I mailed the money to various people anonymously as gifts. And I think giving away those thousands of dollars was the first true act of charity I had ever done. Because there was absolutely no way for any kind of gratitude or elevated feelings to come back to me, because the people had no idea who had sent them that money.
Kevin Kelly：但在那之前，我立了一份遗嘱，处理我仅有的一点东西。我手里还剩下一些钱。我用这笔钱做的其中一件事是去了银行，开了一些五百美元和一千美元的银行本票。我匿名把这些钱作为礼物寄给了不同的人。我想，送出这些钱是我做过的第一次真正的慈善行为。因为这些人根本不知道是谁寄给他们的，所以我不可能从中获得任何感激或高尚的情感回馈。
Kevin Kelly：It was really remarkable to see the consequences of getting an anonymous gift like that. Because when you get a check for $1,000 in the mail, you immediately become suspicious of all your friends of having given that to you. And so there's this suspicion of charity, suspicion of goodness that starts to infect the people that are around you. And you look at someone, you think, "Hm, I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?"
Kevin Kelly：看到收到匿名礼物的结果真是非常了不起。因为当你收到一张一千美元的支票时，你立刻会怀疑是不是身边的某个朋友给你的。于是，一种对慈善的怀疑，对善意的怀疑，开始传染给你周围的人。当你看着某个人时，你会想：“嗯，不知道是不是他给了我那一千美元？”
Ira Glass：Does that make sense? You look at them, and you think, "I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?" And then you act really nice to him. And then the next person you see, the next of your friends, you think, "Could this be the person?" And then you act really nice to them.
Ira Glass：这有道理吗？你看着他们，心想：“不知道是不是他给了我那一千美元？”然后你对他表现得非常友好。接着当你见到下一个人，也就是你的其他朋友时，你会想：“会是这个人吗？”然后你又对他们表现得非常友好。
Ira Glass：I almost want to begin a little speech here about let us all now take up this practice. All of us. Everyone within the sound of my voice. If we all could just do this right now, then I would believe that our little radio show, just 19 minutes into the program, had contributed in some way.
Ira Glass：我真想在这里发表一点演说，呼吁我们所有人现在都开始实践这一点。我们所有人，每一个能听到我声音的人。如果我们所有人现在都能这样做，那么我会相信我们的这个小小广播节目，在开播仅19分钟的时候，就已经以某种方式做出了贡献。
Kevin Kelly：I had enough money left over to basically pay for food and whatnot on my bicycle journey across America. And the path that I had to visit all my brothers and sisters was not a direct route, going from San Francisco to New York. I actually had to go up to Idaho, and back down to Texas, and then back up through Indiana. So it was a 5,000 mile trip. The day which, coincidentally, was exactly six months from when I had this assignment, was October 31. It was Halloween. And so the plan would be that I would ride back home, so that I would come back to die on the day after Halloween.
Kevin Kelly：我剩下的钱刚好够支付我骑自行车横跨美国的饮食等开销。我要去拜访所有兄弟姐妹的路线并非直达，不是从旧金山到纽约那么简单。我实际上得先去爱达荷州，再折回德克萨斯州，然后再北上穿过印第安纳州。所以这是一次五千英里的旅程。巧合的是，距离我接到这个任务整整六个月的那一天是10月31日，万圣节。所以计划是，我会骑车回到家，好在万圣节后的那天死去。
Kevin Kelly：I think there are a lot of people who have trouble staying in the present. There are some people who like to slip into the past as a means to perhaps fantasize or escape. And they find that the past is the place that they retreat to. And I often retreat to the future. I was not a person who planned or had a career staged out, or who had a particular woman he wanted to marry some day, or some vision of a house. The future that I found so hard to give up was a much more insidious type.
Kevin Kelly：我认为很多人都难以活在当下。有些人喜欢溜进过去，以此作为幻想或逃避的手段。他们发现过去是一个可以退缩的避风港。而我经常退缩到未来。我不是那种会做规划、有明确职业生涯目标，或者幻想着将来要娶某个特定的女人、拥有一栋什么样的房子的人。我发现自己难以放弃的未来，是一种更隐蔽的类型。
Kevin Kelly：It was that of I'd like to buy this record because, in the future, I want to hear this song again and again. Or I will read this book, and there are some cool ideas in it because someday I may write an article about this. And it's good to know that. There was a sense in which my entire life was shifted to the future. And the thought of doing something now for the enjoyment, or the pleasures, or the principle of the function of just right now, without any sense at all that it would ever be used again or that it could ever be brought forward, was extremely difficult and disconcerting. And I fought it day by day and tooth by tooth.
Kevin Kelly：比如我买这张唱片是因为我想在未来一遍又一遍地听这首歌。或者我读这本书，是因为里面有一些很酷的想法，将来我可能会写一篇关于这个的文章。知道这些东西是好的。某种程度上，我的整个生活都被推向了未来。而为了当下的享受、乐趣或仅仅因为做这件事本身而去做某事，完全不考虑它将来是否会被再次使用，或者它是否能被带入未来，这对我来说极其困难且令人不安。我每天都在竭力与这种习惯抗争。
Kevin Kelly：One of the ways I dealt with this was that I was actually able, by the last weeks, to not think about my life beyond Halloween. There was a way which I had just-- each time a thought came up about something that was beyond this horizon, I just said, "Nope, can't think about it. It doesn't work. We have to dwell in the present."
Kevin Kelly：我处理这个问题的方法之一，就是到了最后几周，我真的能够不再去想万圣节之后的生活。每当有一个超越这个期限的念头出现时，我就告诉自己：“不，不能想这个。这行不通。我们必须活在当下。”
Kevin Kelly：And at the same time I was doing that, and I was able to do that, I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live. And that having a future is part of what being human is about. And that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of their humanness. And that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present. That one needs to have a past, and one needs to have a future to be fully human.
Kevin Kelly：与此同时，在我这样做并且能够做到的过程中，我也认定这是一种非常不自然且不人道的生活方式。拥有未来是作为人类的一部分。当你剥夺了人类的未来时，也就剥夺了他们很大一部分的人性。完全活在当下其实并不是一件好事。一个人需要有过去，也需要有未来，才能成为一个完整的人。
Kevin Kelly：It was a journey that began at the tomb of Jesus. And as I set off to my own presumed death, I did, indeed, think about Jesus Christ who, according to the Gospels, surrendered his own life in a very knowing way. So we have the history in the Gospels of Jesus's torment in his soul, as he approached what he knew of his anointed time to die. So it was, again, that very harsh information of knowing when you're going to die.
Kevin Kelly：那是一段始于耶稣墓前的旅程。当我踏上通往我预想中的死亡之路时，我的确想到了耶稣基督，根据《福音书》的记载，他以一种非常清醒的方式放弃了自己的生命。所以《福音书》里有耶稣在灵魂受折磨的历史，当时他正接近他所知的受命死亡之时。所以，这同样是一种关于知道自己何时死亡的严酷信息。
Kevin Kelly：And Jesus's soul was in great turmoil and pain because of knowing that. And I think I did experience some of that, not because I had the same weight. It was just my own life. But Jesus prayed that this burden be lifted, and there were days when I did pray that, that if I didn't have to die, I really would rather not.
Kevin Kelly：耶稣的灵魂因为预知这一切而陷入了巨大的动荡和痛苦之中。我想我也经历过其中的一部分，不是因为我有着同样的重负，那只是我自己的生命。但耶稣曾祈求免去这杯苦，而我也确实有几天那样祈祷过：如果我不用死，我真的宁愿不死。
Kevin Kelly：By late fall, I was pedaling through the Appalachians, and it was getting colder and colder. And my hands were freezing on the bicycles, and there was ice on my tents in the morning when I got up. And as each day went on, I was coming closer and closer to terrain that I was familiar with and that felt like home. And I was riding into New Jersey, and I was elated. I was elated that I had accomplished this long journey. And I was elated that I was home to see my parents.
Kevin Kelly：到了深秋，我骑车穿过阿巴拉契亚山脉，天气变得越来越冷。我的手在自行车上冻得僵硬，每天早上起床时，帐篷上都结着冰。随着每一天的推移，我越来越接近我熟悉的土地，那种感觉就像回到了家。我骑车进入新泽西州时，我欣喜若狂。我为自己完成了这趟漫长的旅程而欣喜若狂。我也为能回家见到父母而欣喜若狂。
Kevin Kelly：And I came in to their house on Halloween day. And I was so filled with ideas, and things, and emotions, that I didn't really say very much. And again, I couldn't say very much. I think we had a wonderful dinner. They were, of course, glad to see me because they hadn't seen me in a long time. They knew I was coming back, and we had a wonderful dinner.
Kevin Kelly：我在万圣节那天到了他们的家。我心中充满了想法、事物和情感，以至于我没能说太多话。再说一遍，我确实没法说太多。我想我们吃了一顿很棒的晚餐。他们当然很高兴见到我，因为他们已经很久没见过我了。他们知道我会回来，我们一起享用了一顿美妙的晚餐。
Kevin Kelly：We had baskets of candy, which I gave out to the kids. And we had a discussion that night which was about nothing in particular. It was not about the future. It was just about, I think, talking about our family and my brothers and sisters. And I was telling them all that I  had learned about them. And so it was a very together and, again, not a very dramatic evening, but just a pleasant one, one that you might have a memory about as you were dying, which was not a special evening, but just an ordinary evening.
Kevin Kelly：我们有几篮糖果，我把它们分给了孩子们。那天晚上我们进行了一次交谈，并没有聊什么特别的事。不是关于未来的。我想，只是谈论了我们的家庭，还有我的兄弟姐妹。我告诉他们我所了解到的关于他们的一切。所以那是一个非常融洽、且同样并不怎么戏剧性的夜晚，但却是一个令人愉快的夜晚，那种你可能会在临终时回忆起来的夜晚，不是一个特别的夜晚，而只是一个平凡的夜晚。
Kevin Kelly：And I went to bed that night, which was a very difficult thing to do because I was fully prepared at that point never to wake up again. I had been praying. I had gotten everything arranged. I had fully gone through in my own mind, in my own soul, all the things that I might have regretted. And I had righted as many of those as I thought I could through letters. And I was prepared, as much as anybody could be prepared to die.
Kevin Kelly：那天晚上我上床睡觉了，这非常困难，因为在那一刻，我已经做好了永远不再醒来的充分准备。我一直在祈祷。我已经安排好了一切。我在自己的脑海中，在自己的灵魂深处，仔细梳理了我可能后悔的所有事情。我尽可能通过书信纠正了其中我认为能纠正的部分。我已经做好了准备，像任何一个准备好面对死亡的人一样。
Kevin Kelly：And so I went to bed while the kids were still ringing doorbells. And I went to sleep, because I was very tired after that long trip. And I didn't know what was going to happen the next day. I thought I had done all that I could. And the next morning, I woke up. And the next morning, I woke up, and it was as if-- The next morning I woke up, and it was as if I had the entire-- my entire life again.
Kevin Kelly：于是，当孩子们还在按门铃时，我就上床睡觉了。我睡着了，因为那趟长途旅行后我太累了。我不知道第二天会发生什么。我想我已经尽我所能了。第二天早上，我醒了。第二天早上，我醒了，就好像——第二天早上我醒来时，就好像我重新拥有了整个——我整个人生。
Kevin Kelly：The next morning, I woke up, and I had my entire life again. I had my future again. There was nothing special about the day. It was another ordinary day. I was reborn into ordinariness. But what more could one ask for?
Kevin Kelly：第二天早上，我醒了，我又重新拥有了完整的人生。我又重新拥有了未来。那一天并没有什么特别之处。那是又一个平凡的日子。我重生回到了平凡之中。但人们还能要求什么呢？
Ira Glass：Well, Kevin Kelly is 43 now. That happened when he was 27. In his latest rebirth, he is the executive editor of Wired magazine, a glossy magazine about the future and the present. He told us that he wasn't even sure he has ever even told his parents this story, even this many years later. Anyway, he spoke with me and Paul Tough from the studios of KQED in San Francisco. This is Your Radio Playhouse on WBEZ Chicago.
Ira Glass：嗯，Kevin Kelly现在43岁了。那件事发生在他27岁的时候。在他最近的这次重生中，他是《Wired》杂志的执行主编，这是一本关于未来和当下的光面杂志。他告诉我们，即使过了这么多年，他也不确定自己是否曾向父母讲过这个故事。总之，他和我以及来自旧金山KQED演播室的Paul Tough进行了交谈。这里是WBEZ芝加哥的Your Radio Playhouse。
Receptionist：Good morning. Glass, Jacobson & Associates.
Receptionist：早上好。Glass, Jacobson & Associates律师事务所。
Ira Glass：Hey, is Barry there?
Ira Glass：嘿，Barry在吗？
Receptionist：Pardon me?
Receptionist：你说什么？
Ira Glass：Is Barry there?
Ira Glass：Barry在吗？
Receptionist：Yes, he is. He's on another call. Do you wish to hold, or I could take a message, or you can leave one on his voicemail?
Receptionist：在的。他正在接另一个电话。您需要等待，还是我可以为您转达口信，或者您可以在他的语音信箱留言？
Ira Glass：It's his son.
Ira Glass：我是他儿子。
Receptionist：Uh-huh.
Receptionist：嗯哼。
Ira Glass：Isn't this starting to sound like-- this little dialogue-- isn't it starting to sound like an episode of Dr. Katz? You know that TV show? "This is his son." "Uh-huh. Yeah." Anyway, so I thought I would call my parents in Baltimore and ask for advice on this, our first evening of our brand new radio show, Your Radio Playhouse.
Ira Glass：这段对话听起来是不是很像——这一小段对话——是不是很像《Dr. Katz》的一集？你知道那个电视节目吗？“我是他儿子。”“嗯哼。好的。”总之，我想打个电话给我住在巴尔的摩的父母，征求一下他们的建议，毕竟这是我们这档全新的广播节目《Your Radio Playhouse》的第一晚。
Ira Glass：Can I leave a message with you? Or is it better to use his voicemail?
Ira Glass：我可以留个口信给你吗？还是直接用他的语音信箱更好？
Receptionist：It doesn't matter. I'll put it right on his voicemail.
Receptionist：都可以。我会直接转到他的语音信箱里。
Ira Glass：OK, let's do.
Ira Glass：好的，那就这样吧。
Receptionist：OK, hold on, please.
Receptionist：好的，请稍等。
Receptionist：[MUSIC - "NICE 'N' EASY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
Receptionist：[音乐 - "NICE 'N' EASY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
Ira Glass：This is the story of my childhood right there. Dad is a little too busy to talk. But there's the recording of Frank Sinatra when needed.
Ira Glass：这就是我童年的故事。爸爸忙得没时间说话，但需要的时候就会放Frank Sinatra的录音。
Ira Glass：[TELEPHONE RINGING]
Ira Glass：[电话铃声]
Shirley Glass：Hello?
Shirley Glass：喂？
Ira Glass：Hey, Mom.
Ira Glass：嘿，妈。
Shirley Glass：Oh, hi, Ira.
Shirley Glass：哦，嗨，Ira。
Ira Glass：How you doing?
Ira Glass：你好吗？
Shirley Glass：Fine. Can you hold on a second?
Shirley Glass：很好。你能稍等一下吗？
Ira Glass：Sure.
Ira Glass：当然。
Ira Glass：This is what it's like with my parents. They're so busy. Call them. Put on hold. [SINGING] Baby, what's your hurry?
Ira Glass：这就是我父母的样子。他们太忙了。给他们打电话，就会被挂在等待线上。[唱歌] 宝贝，你着急什么呢？
Ira Glass：When I call my little sister, she works at Disney, and so there's Disney music playing on the hold system. But there's a lot of Disney music. And there's a lot of it that peo--
Ira Glass：当我给我妹妹打电话时，她在迪士尼工作，所以等待系统里会播放迪士尼音乐。但有很多迪士尼音乐。而且有很多音乐是人们——
Shirley Glass：Hi.
Shirley Glass：喂。
Ira Glass：Hi, Mom.
Ira Glass：嗨，妈。
Shirley Glass：Yeah.
Shirley Glass：嗯。
Ira Glass：It's me.
Ira Glass：是我。
Shirley Glass：Yeah.
Shirley Glass：嗯。
Ira Glass：Listen, can I record a quick conversation with you about something?
Ira Glass：听着，我能和你录一段简短的对话吗？聊点什么？
Shirley Glass：What about?
Shirley Glass：聊什么？
Ira Glass：Well, you know the new show goes on the air this week. And as part of the show, we were thinking about having me call around to different people and get advice from them. And I wanted to know if you would have any advice.
Ira Glass：嗯，你知道新节目这周就要开播了。作为节目的一部分，我们在想让我打电话给不同的人，听听他们的建议。我想知道你有什么建议吗？
Shirley Glass：Hm. Do I have any advice? Well, can I ask another question?
Shirley Glass：嗯。我有什么建议吗？好吧，我能问个别的问题吗？
Ira Glass：Sure.
Ira Glass：当然。
Shirley Glass：Who is your target audience?
Shirley Glass：你的目标受众是谁？
Ira Glass：You are such a pro.
Ira Glass：你真是个行家。
Shirley Glass：I'm saying that you're in danger of appealing to a narrow range of listeners if it becomes a little too-- I don't know what word to use.
Shirley Glass：我是说，如果变得太——我不知道该用什么词——你可能会面临受众范围狭窄的风险。
Ira Glass：Artsy.
Ira Glass：艺术化？
Shirley Glass：Artsy, yeah.
Shirley Glass：对，艺术化。
Ira Glass：Are you and Dad still worried about me making a living in public radio? I know just for years, you were urging me to just get out and get, basically, any job in TV that I possibly could. But now that I've got my own show, are you guys still worried? Or do you feel like things are going OK? Do you want me to get into television still?
Ira Glass：你和爸爸还在担心我靠公共广播维生吗？我知道多年来，你们一直催我离开，让我随便找一份电视方面的工作。但现在我有了自己的节目，你们还在担心吗？还是觉得一切都好？你们还想让我去搞电视吗？
Shirley Glass：Now that Hugh Grant is such a big star, and everybody who sees you or sees your picture thinks how much you look like Hugh Grant, that fires up that TV thing again in me.
Shirley Glass：现在Hugh Grant是大明星了，每个见到你或看到你照片的人都会想你有多像Hugh Grant，这又让我燃起了那种让你去搞电视的想法。
Ira Glass：All right. I'm stopping the tape. This is me live. That was the tape. Only my mother could possibly believe this. Only a mother could pretty much believe this. Other adults see me, and the thought that goes through their head is not Hugh Grant. The thought that goes through their head is tall Jew.
Ira Glass：好吧。我把录音关了。现在是现场直播，刚才那是录音。只有我妈才可能相信这个。只有母亲才会相信这种事。其他成年人见到我时，脑子里闪过的念头绝不是Hugh Grant。他们脑子里想的是：个子高高的犹太人。
Shirley Glass：Well, gosh, wouldn't they want this wonderful humanistic, intelligent reporter who looks like Hugh Grant?
Shirley Glass：哎呀，他们难道不会想要这位长得像Hugh Grant、充满人文关怀又聪明的记者吗？
Ira Glass：All right. Yeah, let's move on.
Ira Glass：好了，咱们继续吧。
Shirley Glass：What's the theme for this week?
Shirley Glass：这周的主题是什么？
Ira Glass：The theme for this week is new beginnings. And we have several stories, people telling about various ways in which their life began anew at some point.
Ira Glass：这周的主题是“新的开始”。我们有几个故事，人们讲述了他们在生活中以各种方式重获新生的经历。
Shirley Glass：That's very interesting, because I just did an interview this morning with a newspaper reporter about roman--
Shirley Glass：这很有趣，因为我今天早上刚接受了一位报社记者的采访，关于浪漫……
Ira Glass：I'm just going to stop the tape again. This is my whole life. I call my mom for an interview, and it's not even her first interview of the day. I was lucky to get a booking. She's a therapist, and sometimes she gets called by the papers and stuff.
Ira Glass：我又要关掉录音了。这就是我的生活。我给妈妈打电话采访，这竟然还不是她今天的第一场采访。我能预约到她真是走运。她是心理治疗师，有时会接到报社之类的采访邀约。
Shirley Glass：--mance, romantic love. And people's expectations about relationships. And one of the things I believe is that there are a lot of people who are good at beginnings, but they're not good at middles.
Shirley Glass：……浪漫，浪漫的爱情。以及人们对关系的期望。我相信的一点是，很多人擅长开始，但不擅长过程。
Ira Glass：Which means what?
Ira Glass：这是什么意思？
Shirley Glass：It means that they like the beginning, where there's all this idealization and romantic projections. And the other person can be who they think they should be, rather than who they are. And when they get to the middle phase--
Shirley Glass：意思是他们喜欢开始阶段，那时候充满了理想化和浪漫的投射。对方可以成为他们想象中应该成为的样子，而不是真实的自我。而当他们进入中间阶段时……
Ira Glass：All right. I'm just going to stop the tape. Listen, all of you in the audience right now, let's just agree right now, it's the very beginning of our relationship. It's the very beginning of our radio relationship right now. This is our little first little radio date, and I just don't want any idealizing on either side. OK? Let's just make eye contact right now. Remember what Joe Franklin said about the eye contact. No idealizing.
Ira Glass：好吧，我还是关掉录音吧。听着，你们现在所有的听众，我们现在就达成共识，这正是我们关系的开端。这是我们广播关系的起点。这是我们的第一次广播约会，我不想双方有任何理想化，好吗？现在让我们进行眼神交流。记住Joe Franklin关于眼神交流的话，不要理想化。
Shirley Glass：--where there's more of a reality-based relationship, they run away from it because it's not as exciting.
Shirley Glass：……当进入基于现实的关系时，他们就会逃避，因为那没那么令人兴奋。
Ira Glass：It's interesting that you say that because, actually, as we've approached the first show, I've realized that I am much more comfortable with the notion of every day, work-a-day radio work, and being on every week, and having pieces on the air. But the notion of saying in a really big way, "OK, this is the beginning. It's the beginning, and we're going to have a big beginning, and we're going to make an epic statement," I feel very uncomfortable with.
Ira Glass：你这么说很有趣，因为实际上，随着第一期节目的临近，我意识到我更习惯于日常的广播工作，每周都播出，让作品在广播里呈现。但对于那种大张旗鼓地说“好的，这是一个开始。这是个开端，我们要有一个盛大的开局，我们要发表一个史诗般的声明”的这种想法，我感到非常不自在。
Shirley Glass：So you are good at middles.
Shirley Glass：所以你很擅长处理中间部分。
Ira Glass：I'm better, I think, at middles than at beginnings.
Ira Glass：我想，比起开头，我更擅长中间部分。
Shirley Glass：That's good. That's good because practically all of life is the middle.
Shirley Glass：那很好。那很好，因为生活几乎全都是中间部分。
Ira Glass：We have gotten so deep here. I never expected that it was going to get so deep. I'm just very pleased at how deep this has gotten. Now you're sitting there, you're thinking, "Is he making fun of me? What's happening now? Where are you?" No, I'm not. I'm not, actually. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. You have nothing to worry about.
Ira Glass：我们在这里谈得太深奥了。我从没想过会谈得这么深。我对谈话能达到这种深度感到非常高兴。现在你坐在那儿，心想：“他在取笑我吗？现在是怎么回事？你在哪里？”不，我没有。真的没有。我没有。我没有。我没有。你不用担心。
Shirley Glass：Are we going to get a tape of this since we're outside the Chicago listening area?
Shirley Glass：既然我们在芝加哥收听范围之外，我们能拿到录音带吗？
Ira Glass：Depending on how you sound, yeah.
Ira Glass：看你表现得如何吧，可以的。
Shirley Glass：OK.
Shirley Glass：好的。
Ira Glass：Well, that's my mom, Shirley Glass, speaking to us from Baltimore. I don't think she's going to get a tape. I do not think she's going to get a tape.
Ira Glass：嗯，那就是我的母亲Shirley Glass，从巴尔的摩打来。我觉得她拿不到录音带。我不认为她能拿到录音带。
Ira Glass：Well, next on our little playhouse stage, we have Mr. Lawrence Steger. Now those of you who have been listening carefully to our program and taking notes, and I know there are many of you out there, you know what I'm supposed to do at this point. You know because you were listening carefully to Joe Franklin at the very beginning of our program.
Ira Glass：好了，接下来在我们的微型剧场舞台上，我们要请出Lawrence Steger先生。那些一直认真收听我们节目并做笔记的朋友们——我知道你们很多人都在做——你们知道我此时该做什么。你们知道，因为你们在节目一开始就认真听了Joe Franklin的话。
Joe Franklin：Above all, get the plug fast.
Joe Franklin：最重要的是，快点打广告。
Ira Glass：That's right. Well, thank you, Joe Franklin. Lawrence Steger is a filmmaker and a performance artist, just back from performing in Glasgow, Scotland. He's going back there in January to collaborate with the performance artist, Ron Athey, who lives here in Chicago. And basically, we contacted Lawrence, and we told him the story that you heard over the course of the last half-hour, Kevin Kelly's story, this guy who believes he only has six months to live, goes on this cross-country road trip.
Ira Glass：没错。好了，谢谢你，Joe Franklin。Lawrence Steger是一位电影制作人和表演艺术家，刚从苏格兰格拉斯哥的演出回来。他一月份会回去那里，与住在这里芝加哥的表演艺术家Ron Athey合作。基本上，我们联系了Lawrence，告诉了他你们在过去半小时里听到的故事，就是Kevin Kelly的故事，这个认为自己只剩下六个月生命的人，进行了一次横穿全国的公路旅行。
Ira Glass：And as it turned out, when Lawrence Steger found out, the day that he found out that he was HIV positive, this was five years ago, on that day, it was the exact day that he and a friend left on a cross-country car trip. So we commissioned him to do a little piece about his experience. And here it is.
Ira Glass：结果证明，当Lawrence Steger得知自己HIV呈阳性的那天，那是五年前的事了，就在那一天，他和朋友正好出发进行了一次横穿全国的汽车旅行。所以我们委托他创作了一段关于他那段经历的作品。现在，请看。
Lawrence Steger：Title. Road. Treatment. It's shot entirely on video, mostly handheld. Shaky, out of focus, bad color. Overblown color actually. Sort of the way colors are separated on an old television console, yet still has all the outlines of the images repeated. The outlines of the images, the silhouettes, repeated over and over, ad nauseam, and fading into each other.
Lawrence Steger：标题。道路。治疗。它完全是用录像拍摄的，大部分是手持拍摄。画面晃动，失焦，色彩糟糕。其实是色彩过饱和。就像旧电视机里色彩分离的方式，但图像的所有轮廓仍然反复出现。图像的轮廓，那些剪影，一遍又一遍地重复，令人作呕，并互相交融。
Lawrence Steger：Can I get this microphone adjusted a little, so I don't have to lean over so much?
Lawrence Steger：我能调整一下麦克风吗，这样我就不用弯腰弯得那么厉害了？
Ira Glass：Yeah, sure. Just pull that.
Ira Glass：可以，没问题。拉一下那个就好。
Lawrence Steger：Check one, two, three. Sound better? Yeah. Sorry. Thanks.
Lawrence Steger：一、二、三，试音。听起来好点了吗？好的。抱歉。谢谢。
Lawrence Steger：Synopsis. The story concerns Luke, gay, white, Midwestern, late twenties. Follows Luke on the day that he is informed of his HIV positive status. Luke cops a stance of cold, brittle, not unlike the Harrison Ford narration on Blade Runner, but there's a hint of vulnerability to Luke.
Lawrence Steger：剧情概要。故事关于Luke，男同性恋，白人，中西部人，二十多岁。讲述了Luke得知自己HIV呈阳性当天的情况。Luke表现出一种冷漠、脆弱的姿态，就像《银翼杀手》里Harrison Ford的旁白一样，但Luke身上有一丝脆弱。
Lawrence Steger：Have we got the Harrison Ford or the Rutger Hauer voice?
Lawrence Steger：我们用的是Harrison Ford的声音还是Rutger Hauer的声音？
Ira Glass：Yeah.
Ira Glass：是那个。
Lawrence Steger：Great. Roll it.
Lawrence Steger：太棒了。开始吧。
Harrison Ford：Enhance 5719. Track 45 left.
Harrison Ford：增强 5719。追踪左侧 45 度。
Lawrence Steger：Great. Take it under me. That's great. Story follows Luke. He's accompanied by his college buddy, Bill, and both are packed for a road trip across the country to San Francisco.
Lawrence Steger：很好。把它放到我下面。太棒了。故事跟随 Luke。他由大学好友 Bill 陪同，两人都收拾好行装，准备开车穿越全国前往旧金山。
Lawrence Steger：This isn't the right section of Blade Runner. Can you just kill the Blade Runner?
Lawrence Steger：这不是《银翼杀手》的正确片段。你能把《银翼杀手》的声音去掉吗？
Lawrence Steger：Locations. Car interior. Gas station exterior. HIV clinic parking lot. HIV clinic interior. Highway. Music. Strauss's four last songs, particularly "Ruhe, meine Seele!" sung by Dame Janet Baker.
Lawrence Steger：场景。车内。加油站外。艾滋病诊所停车场。艾滋病诊所内部。高速公路。音乐。施特劳斯的《最后四首歌》，尤其是 Dame Janet Baker 演唱的《入睡吧，我的灵魂！》。
Lawrence Steger：Can you take it under me? Hold.
Lawrence Steger：你能把它放到我下面吗？停。
Lawrence Steger：Follows Luke and his friend Bill to the gas station and to the clinic, the last stop before getting on the highway.
Lawrence Steger：跟随 Luke 和他的朋友 Bill 去加油站，然后去诊所，这是上高速公路前的最后一站。
Lawrence Steger：OK. Take it out. Take out the Janet Baker.
Lawrence Steger：好的。把它拿掉。把 Janet Baker 的歌拿掉。
Lawrence Steger：Bill loads one hits of pot while driving on the way to the gas station and to the clinic.
Lawrence Steger：Bill 在去加油站和诊所的路上边开车边抽了一口大麻。
Lawrence Steger：Can we nix that Strauss music? It's too mournful. There's really no music on the soundtrack. It's stark, crisp. Maybe some songs coming from the radio at the clinic's desk?
Lawrence Steger：我们能把施特劳斯的音乐去掉吗？太忧伤了。原声带里真的不需要音乐。要冷峻、干脆。也许诊所柜台的收音机里可以传出一些歌？
Lawrence Steger：[RADIO STATIC]
Lawrence Steger：[收音机静电声]
Ira Glass：Great. And definitely from the car radio mixed with surfing on an AM radio. No music.
Ira Glass：很好。一定要和车里的收音机混合，还有调频时的噪音。不要音乐。
Ira Glass：The drama is constantly being undermined through the cool, collective quality of Luke's demeanor. He seems detached, quote, "I am not sure how I feel. I feel a little sad, sort of mad. I guess blank. But I'm OK. I'm sure I'll get a handle on it," end quote. Luke thinks he's sounding like a short story assignment in a creative writing class or, worse, trapped inside an artsy novel.
Ira Glass：戏剧感不断被 Luke 冷静、集体的行为举止所削弱。他显得很超然，引用：“我不确定我的感受。我感觉有点难过，又有点生气。我想是一片空白。但我没事。我肯定能应付。”引用结束。Luke 觉得自己听起来像创意写作课上的短篇小说作业，或者更糟的是，被困在了一部矫揉造作的小说里。
Ira Glass：Luke imagines himself in a television dramatization of himself. Camera pulls back from behind Luke's head, sort of on a mini-crane. Camera floats, hovers over the back of Luke's head. "The ceiling of the car must be incredibly high," he thinks to himself.
Ira Glass：Luke 把自己想象成他自己电视改编剧里的角色。摄像机从 Luke 的脑后拉开，像是在一个小型摇臂上。摄像机悬浮着，在 Luke 的后脑勺上方盘旋。“车顶一定很高，”他心想。
Ira Glass：Bill pulls into the closest parking spot in the clinic, blows out the last of the one-hit, and, as he's knocking the brass pipe into the ashtray, turns to Luke with that slightly watery look in his eyes from too much intake. Luke takes it as one of those Care Bear looks that he's experienced before from Bill. A little clumsy since Bill has to force his face into a sympathetic posture. Quick close-up on the corner of Bill's mouth.
Ira Glass：Bill 把车停进诊所最近的车位，吐出最后一口大麻烟，当他把黄铜烟斗敲向烟灰缸时，转头看向 Luke，眼神因为吸食过多而显得有些湿润。Luke 把这看作是他以前从 Bill 那里体验过的那种“爱心熊”般的眼神。有点笨拙，因为 Bill 必须强迫自己的脸做出同情的表情。Bill 嘴角的快速特写。
Ira Glass：There's a moment of anger flashing in Luke when he registers Bill's look. When Bill asks him, "What are you thinking about?" Luke responds, "Who's thinking? Nothing." "I hate thinking I'm in a novel," he thinks to himself. Cut to interior of the clinic, the reception area.
Ira Glass：当 Luke 注意到 Bill 的眼神时，心中闪过一丝愤怒。当 Bill 问他：“你在想什么？”Luke 回答道：“谁在想？什么都没想。”“我讨厌这种觉得自己身处小说里的感觉，”他心想。切换到诊所内部，接待处。
Ira Glass：Can we change this sound bed here?
Ira Glass：我们能换一下这里的背景音吗？
Ira Glass：[ROMANTIC MUSIC PLAYING]
Ira Glass：[浪漫音乐响起]
Ira Glass：Great. Take it down just a-- Great.
Ira Glass：很好。调低一点——很好。
Ira Glass：In the scene that we talked about on the phone, the clinic waiting room scene, that scene flips back and forth between various security black-and-white cameras mounted at the ceilings. The nurse assigned to Luke's anonymous number is a black drag queen named Stephanie, who wears a full nurse's outfit complete with a little paper hat that sits atop of her freshly coiffed hairdo. She's the only one in the clinic who wears a real uniform. Stephanie has the longest fingernails that Luke has ever seen on anyone. Luke thinks briefly about how the fingernails keep on growing even after a person dies, but he pushes that thought away with this fingers to his forehead, wonders why he is thinking about that. It's that novel thing again.
Ira Glass：在我们电话里讨论的那个场景，诊所候诊室的场景，在天花板上安装的各种黑白安保摄像头之间来回切换。分配给 Luke 匿名编号的护士是一位名叫 Stephanie 的黑人变装皇后，她穿着全套护士装，精心打理的发型上还戴着一顶纸质小帽子。她是诊所里唯一穿正规制服的人。Stephanie 有 Luke 见过的最长的指甲。Luke 短暂地想到即使人死后指甲还会继续生长，但他用手指按住额头推开了这个想法，纳闷自己为什么会想这个。又是那种小说带来的感觉。
Ira Glass：Stephanie, the drag queen nurse, walks Luke back to the small cubicles that the tests are administered in and then used to relay the results. Luke's narrator imagines how many people have been in these cubicles and what they would look like if they were all piled on top of one another. Piles of tested bodies. Cut to Stephanie closing the hollow core door, makes that hollow core door sound.
Ira Glass：变装皇后护士 Stephanie 带 Luke 走进进行测试的小隔间，这些隔间也用来传达结果。Luke 的叙述者想象有多少人曾在这个隔间里，如果把他们堆在一起会是什么样子。成堆的受试者身体。剪辑到 Stephanie 关上空心门，发出那种空心门的声音。
Ira Glass：Do we have that on cart?
Ira Glass：我们有那段录音吗？
Ira Glass：[SOUND OF HOLLOW DOOR CLOSING]
Ira Glass：[空心门关上的声音]
Ira Glass：Perfect. Maybe a shot from a security camera that shows all of the cubicles in the clinic. Luke imagines himself in a George Tooker painting that was reproduced in his sixth grade reader. He wonders what his sixth grade teacher would think of Stephanie. He wonders if his sixth grade teacher was ever tested. He imagines her body in the pileup of bodies who have come to the clinic.
Ira Glass：完美。或许可以拍一个安保摄像头的镜头，展示诊所里所有的隔间。Luke想象自己置身于一幅乔治·塔克（George Tooker）的画中，那幅画曾印在他六年级的课本里。他想知道六年级的老师会如何看待Stephanie。他想知道六年级的老师是否曾接受过测试。他想象着老师的身体也出现在诊所里那些堆叠的尸体中。
Ira Glass：Stephanie has been saying something, and Luke has to blink his eyes again to refocus. He explains to Stephanie that he has been expecting this result, that he's experienced a large share of AIDS, cared for, and, likewise, buried lots of his friends. But it doesn't seem to come as a surprise. Stephanie says, "You can cry or hold my hand. I just want you to sit for a moment and let it sink in." Luke thinks, "Whatever."
Ira Glass：Stephanie一直在说些什么，Luke不得不再次眨眼以重新聚焦。他向Stephanie解释说他一直预料到会有这个结果，他经历过很多艾滋病病例，照顾过，也同样埋葬过许多朋友。但这似乎并不让人感到惊讶。Stephanie说：“你可以哭，也可以握住我的手。我只是希望你能坐一会儿，让这件事沉淀下来。”Luke想：“随便吧。”
Ira Glass：Cut to Bill in waiting room, flipping through People 's The Year in Pictures. Cut back to close-up of Luke, forehead wrinkled. He thinks his narrator wants him to get out of the cubicle. He waits for Stephanie to finish her spiel, thanks her, and shakes her hand, getting a slight scrape from one of the fingernails. Close-up on Luke's hand, no scratch. The walls seem to pulsate as Luke walks down the hallway to the reception area. He tries to be as blank as possible to Bill.
Ira Glass：切换到等候室里的Bill，他正翻阅《人物》杂志的《年度图片》。切回Luke的特写，他眉头紧锁。他觉得他的叙述者想让他离开隔间。他等Stephanie说完她的那套说辞，感谢了她，并与她握手，指甲不小心划过。Luke的手部特写，没有伤痕。当Luke穿过走廊走向接待区时，墙壁似乎在搏动。他尽量在Bill面前保持面无表情。
Ira Glass：I'm not sure about this final section. I know that we talked about it ending on the highway with the car being surrounded by bikers on their way to the Sturgis bikers' rally. But now I like the idea of it ending on the highway entrance ramp.
Ira Glass：我不确定这最后一部分该怎么处理。我知道我们讨论过以车子在高速公路上被前往斯特吉斯（Sturgis）摩托车拉力赛的车队包围作为结局。但现在我更喜欢它在高速公路入口匝道处结束的想法。
Ira Glass：Cut to interior of car pulling out of parking lot. Luke keeps looking straight ahead, as he murmurs, "I'm positive." Long, slow pan from the back of Luke's head to the back of Bill's. There's no reaction in either of their faces or, better, the profiles of their faces. This is the longest shot. They don't look at each other.
Ira Glass：切入车内镜头，车子驶出停车场。Luke始终目视前方，喃喃自语道：“我呈阳性。”镜头缓慢地从Luke的后脑勺平移到Bill的后脑勺。他们两人的脸上都没有表情，或者说，侧脸轮廓上没有任何反应。这是最长的一个镜头。他们互不相看。
Ira Glass：Perhaps this scene would be shot in blue screen with the camera in the backseat and the sky surrounding the two heads of Bill and Luke having that old, scratchy, 16 millimeter time lapse exposure, so the clouds seem to be moving at a rapid pace. Flickers, flips back and forth between real sky and blue screen backdrop. Voice comes up on a car radio. "Trying not to think of the future. Just live in the present moment." Something like that. You got that? It comes onto the radio.
Ira Glass：或许这个场景可以用蓝幕拍摄，摄像机放在后座，Bill和Luke两个人的头周围是那种老旧、带划痕的16毫米延时曝光天空，云朵看起来移动得很快。画面在真实天空和蓝幕背景之间闪烁、跳跃。车载收音机里传出声音。“尽量不去想未来。活在当下。”类似这样的话。听到了吗？它在收音机里响起来。
Kevin Kelly：I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live, and that having a future is part of what being human is about, and that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of the humanness, and that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present, that one needs to have a past.
Kevin Kelly：我还认为，那是一种完全不自然且没有人道的生活方式，拥有未来是身为人类的一部分。当你剥夺了人类的未来，你就剥夺了很大一部分的人性。事实上，完全活在当下并不是一件好事，人需要有过去。
Lawrence Steger：Luke comments to Bill, "Live entirely in the present, huh?" Bill drives and looks out the corner of his right eye to see what position Luke is holding his head in. Luke looks outside passenger window and, every once in a while, turns to glance at Bill. Long pause. There's dead air. Cut to Luke's point of view. Car is pulling onto entrance ramp of highway. Luke sees hitchhiker with a sign that he stands for any remote meaning to the narrative. Luke sees himself outside of his own story. He can't read the hitchhiker's sign. He knows that he's on a long silent journey. He leans over to turn off the radio. Cut to black.
Lawrence Steger：Luke对Bill评论道：“完全活在当下，是吗？”Bill开着车，用右眼余光瞥了一眼，观察Luke头部保持的位置。Luke看向副驾驶窗外，并不时转头看一眼Bill。长久的沉默。空气凝固了。切到Luke的视角。车子正驶入高速公路入口匝道。Luke看到了一个搭车人，举着一块牌子，他觉得这牌子对叙事有着某种遥远的含义。Luke看到了故事之外的自己。他读不出搭车人牌子上的字。他知道自己正处于一段漫长而沉默的旅程中。他俯身关掉了收音机。画面切黑。
Lawrence Steger：[MUSIC - "(UH-OH) GET OUT OF THE CAR" BY THE TRENIERS]
Lawrence Steger：[音乐 - THE TRENIERS演唱的“(UH-OH) GET OUT OF THE CAR”]
Ira Glass：Well, Lawrence Steger is a Chicago performance artist and filmmaker.
Ira Glass：嗯，Lawrence Steger是一位芝加哥的行为艺术家和电影制作人。
Ira Glass：This is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. OK, what am I doing right now? What am I doing right now? That's right. That's right. Eye contact.
Ira Glass：这里是《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse）。我是Ira Glass。好吧，我现在在做什么？我现在在做什么？没错。就是这样。眼神交流。
Joe Franklin：Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
Joe Franklin：直视对方的眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
Ira Glass：That's right. Advice from the master. OK. Let's review our program so far. Let's just review. Let's just get things straight right now. Our stories so far have been about people whose futures were taken from them and were thrown into the present in one way or another.
Ira Glass：没错。大师的建议。好的。让我们回顾一下目前的节目内容。让我们回顾一下。让我们先把事情理清楚。我们目前讲述的故事都是关于那些未来被剥夺，并以某种方式被抛入当下的人们。
Ira Glass：I guess when any big emotional moment happens, you are thrown in the present in a really aggressive, aggressive way, whether you choose to or not. You have this hyper sense of reality. Well, the next story is about someone whose future was taken from him when he was wrongly imprisoned for 20 years. And his sentence was commuted two years ago. And he found himself reborn into everyday life.
Ira Glass：我想，当任何重大的情感时刻发生时，无论你是否选择，你都会被非常强烈、非常猛烈地抛入当下。你对现实有一种超强的感知力。那么，下一个故事是关于一个未来被剥夺的人，他被错误监禁了20年。两年前他的刑期被减免了。他发现自己重生回到了日常生活。
Ed Ryder：It was like I just-- I don't know. It seemed like the oxygen was even different. You know what I mean? The air seemed to be thinner.
Ed Ryder：就好像我刚——我不知道。感觉连氧气都不同了。你知道我的意思吗？空气似乎变稀薄了。
Ed Ryder：I'll tell you what's been a real kick for me, getting up, cooking breakfast. Making pancakes, and eggs, and bacon, and stuff like that. It sounds drab maybe to the common-- everybody would think of that as, "That's really drab." But for me, that's really exciting. And that's one of the things I always dreamed of doing. I also dreamt of finding a very lovely lady, and I have. Inside, I'm happy. Inside.
Ed Ryder：我告诉你什么对我来说才是真正的乐趣：起床，做早餐。做煎饼、鸡蛋、培根之类的东西。对普通人来说，这听起来可能很枯燥——每个人都会觉得，“那真是太枯燥了。”但对我来说，那真的很令人兴奋。这也是我一直梦想做的事情之一。我还梦想找到一位非常可爱的女士，我也找到了。内心深处，我是快乐的。内心深处。
Ira Glass：This is Ed Ryder. He was in prison for murder and was doing time in Graterford Prison in Pennsylvania. And a few years ago, a key witness who had testified against him admitted to lying while under oath, and other evidence came forward. He was made a free man. Back when he was in Graterford Prison, he played trumpet, and he sang with a jazz band. And that whole time, he dreamed of this new life, a new life that he would have outside as a professional musician. And that's what he's working on. That's what he's working on right now. And he's playing. He doesn't have a CD yet, but he's playing gigs in the real world.
Ira Glass：这位是Ed Ryder。他因谋杀罪入狱，曾在宾夕法尼亚州的格雷特福德（Graterford）监狱服刑。几年前，一名曾指证他的关键证人承认在宣誓后撒了谎，其他证据也浮出水面。他重获自由。当他在格雷特福德监狱时，他吹小号，并与一支爵士乐队一起演唱。在那段时间里，他一直梦想着这种新生活，一种他在监狱外作为专业音乐家拥有的新生活。这就是他正在努力的方向。这就是他现在正在做的事情。而且他正在演奏。他还没有CD，但他正在现实世界中进行演出。
Ed Ryder：The first time I played, when I got out of prison, I didn't feel compelled to be so exact like I did when I was at Graterford. Inmates are the worst, critical people in the world. They criticize anything you do. In prison, you have a lot of musicians. After all, musicians, they don't make no money, so I guess the first place you find them at is in prison. But you have a lot of guys who are musicians.
Ed Ryder：我出狱后第一次演奏时，我没有像在格雷特福德时那样强迫自己必须那么精准。囚犯是世界上最挑剔的人。他们会批评你做的任何事情。在监狱里，你有很多音乐家。毕竟，音乐家赚不到钱，所以我想你最先找到他们的地方就是在监狱。但你确实有很多身为音乐家的家伙。
Ed Ryder：And even though they might not be actively playing anymore, they'll be quick to criticize you, whether the chord is not right, or whether you didn't flatten the ninth, whether you didn't raise this fifth, or you guys didn't play the changes right. Although it might not have took away from the structure of the music, it's just that, I guess you can say that prisoners have a tendency to think like classical musicians would. Everything has to be perfect and exact the way it's heard. And everything has to be like that. There's no going against the grain.
Ed Ryder：即便他们可能不再活跃地演奏了，他们也会很快地批评你，不管是和弦不对，还是你没降九音，或者你没升五音，又或者是你们没把变奏弹对。虽然这可能并没有削弱音乐的结构，但我猜你可以说，囚犯们有一种像古典音乐家那样思考的倾向。一切都必须完美，必须和听到的完全一致。所有事情都必须那样。没有反其道而行之的空间。
Ed Ryder：And here, in the world, people are a little different. They don't concern themselves so much with that, as much as how are you entertaining us? How are you helping us to feel better about ourselves? How are you making us feel better? At Graterford, there is nothing you can do to make them feel better, except to release them.
Ed Ryder：而在外面的世界，人们稍微有些不同。他们并不那么在意这些，而更在意你如何娱乐我们？你如何帮我们感觉更好？你如何让我们感到快乐？在 Graterford，你什么也做不了来让他们感觉更好，除非释放他们。
Ed Ryder：So if you can play for a Graterford audience, you don't even look for an applause. Just as long as they don't boo you, you're all right. If they can't find nothing wrong with the music, they'll tell you, "You just didn't turn right. When you had the horn up, you didn't hold it on a 45 degree angle. It didn't look right." So they'll find something.
Ed Ryder：所以如果你能为 Graterford 的观众演奏，你甚至不必期待掌声。只要他们不发出嘘声，你就做得不错。如果他们找不到音乐有什么毛病，他们会告诉你：“你刚才转位不对。当你把号举起来时，没保持45度角。看起来不对劲。”总之，他们总能挑出毛病。
Ira Glass：Now you know how we heard people earlier in the program talk about the importance of living in the present. But when we interviewed Ed Ryder, he pointed out that, in prison, the most important thing is to keep your eye on the future, on the day that you're going to get out. And that the guys who just live in the present do really badly, because, of course, the present is so terrible.
Ira Glass：现在你知道了我们在节目早些时候听到的那些人谈论活在当下的重要性。但当我们采访 Ed Ryder 时，他指出在监狱里，最重要的事情是把目光放在未来，放在你即将出狱的那一天。那些只活在当下的人往往过得很糟糕，因为，当然，现在的生活太可怕了。
Ed Ryder：I think when I was in prison, I dreamed more about the future in my head. I just had a lot of plans, a lot of things that I just dreamed about, I just dreamed of doing and dreamed of accomplishing. You're forced almost to. You know what I mean? You have nothing else to look forward to but tomorrow. You're constantly hoping and hoping. You're trying to plan something for the future.
Ed Ryder：我想我在监狱时，脑子里更多是梦想未来。我有很多计划，有很多我梦想去做、梦想去完成的事情。你几乎是被迫这样做的。你明白我的意思吗？除了明天，你没有什么可期待的。你不断地希望着、期盼着。你试图为未来规划些什么。
Ira Glass：We asked him if he is still playing the same music now that his future is here and he's out. And we thought that maybe the songs that he used to play would just bring back these hard memories of prison that he'd rather just as soon avoid. But he said, no, he plays the same numbers now that he used to, though sometimes they mean something different to him today.
Ira Glass：我们问他现在未来已来、他已出狱，是否还在演奏同样的音乐。我们原以为他过去常演奏的歌曲可能会勾起他宁愿回避的监狱痛苦回忆。但他表示不会，他现在演奏的曲目和以前一样，尽管有时它们在今天对他有了不同的意义。
Ed Ryder：When I was in Graterford, I always listened to it. I had a tape of "God Bless the Child That's Got His Own" by Billie Holiday. And what it meant to me when I was at Graterford-- and it has the same meaning now, but it's different. In the sense that, when I was at Graterford, when she said, "Them that's got shall get, Them that's not shall lose. So the Bible says, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, But God bless the child that has his own."
Ed Ryder：当我在 Graterford 时，我总是听它。我有一盘 Billie Holiday 的《God Bless the Child That's Got His Own》磁带。当我在 Graterford 时，它对我意味着什么——现在它仍有同样的含义，但却有所不同。意思是，在 Graterford 时，当她唱到：“有的人会有，没的人会失去。圣经如是说，至今仍是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子。”
Ed Ryder：Well, in my mind, at Graterford, I thought that, yes, I was the child that had his own, because I was out here on my own. I had no help at the time. There was no hope. I seen no way. I was like a child. I was like a child because I had no one I can turn to. My parents had passed. I had no one I could turn to.
Ed Ryder：嗯，在 Graterford，我当时想，是的，我就是那个拥有自己一切的孩子，因为我是在这里独立支撑。那时我没有任何帮助。看不到希望。我看不到出路。我就像个孩子。我像个孩子是因为我无人可依。我的父母已经去世了。我没有可以求助的人。
Ed Ryder：And I felt like every time I would listen to that, I felt as though she was talking directly to me. And for me, that meant that I was on my own in this prison situation. And I was going to have to make it the best way that I could. And I was going to have to muster all the energy that I could possibly muster. Now when I was released and I heard the same song again, it still had that meaning, but now it's a different-- I'm on my own differently because I'm not in prison anymore.
Ed Ryder：我感觉每次听这首歌时，就像她在直接跟我说话。对我来说，这意味着在那种监狱环境下我只能靠自己。我必须尽我所能做到最好。我必须鼓起我所能鼓起的所有力量。现在当我获释再次听到这首歌时，它依然有那种含义，但现在它不同了——我以另一种方式独立，因为我不再身陷囹圄。
Ed Ryder：That's not the struggle no more. It's me. But I'm on my own now because I've got things that I have to do. I have responsibilities now that I have to take care of. I have bills that I have to pay. I have job responsibility.
Ed Ryder：那不再是挣扎了。那是为了我。但我现在独立是因为我有必须要做的事情。我有了必须承担的责任。我必须支付账单。我有工作责任。
Ed Ryder：I have a lot of other things that I have to do, and I have to do these things on my own now. I don't have no prison guards waking me up in the morning, telling me, "Hey, it's time to get up," or "It's time to go eat, " or "It's time where you guys can go to a shower." I don't have that anymore. I'm on my own. So all this now is dependent upon me and my own initiative.
Ed Ryder：我还有很多其他必须要做的事情，我现在必须靠自己去做。我没有狱警在早上叫醒我，告诉我“嘿，起床了”，或者“该去吃饭了”，或者“该去洗澡了”。我不再有那些了。我独立了。所以这一切现在都取决于我和我自己的主动性。
Ed Ryder：[SINGING] Them that's got shall get, them that's not will lose. So the Bible said, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. You know the strong get more, while the weak ones fade. Empty pockets don't, they don't make the grade. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. Money, you've got lots of friends. They all keep hanging around your door. But when money's gone and all of the spendings end, they don't come around, they won't come around no more. Rich relations give a crust of bread and such. Go on and help yourself, but you better not take too much. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own. God bless the child that's got his own.
Ed Ryder：[歌唱] 有的人会有，没的人会失去。圣经如是说，至今仍是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子，拥有自己一切的孩子。你知道强者更强，弱者消亡。囊中羞涩的人，他们无法达到标准。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子，拥有自己一切的孩子。有了钱，你就有了很多朋友。他们都在你门前徘徊。但当钱花光了，挥霍结束了，他们就不再来了，他们再也不会来了。富有的亲戚给一片面包之类。去吧，自己动手，但最好别拿太多。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子。上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子。
Ed Ryder：That's basically some of it.
Ed Ryder：基本上就是这些。
Ira Glass：Ed Ryder joining us in the playhouse from the studios of WHYY in Philadelphia, speaking with me and associate producer Nancy Updike. Ed Ryder's a big Billie Holiday fanatic. That was the word he used, "fanatic," when we asked him about it. So when we asked him to play a number with his horn, with his trumpet, he played "Lover Man."
Ira Glass：Ed Ryder 在费城的 WHYY 工作室加入我们的演播室，与我和助理制片人 Nancy Updike 谈话。Ed Ryder 是 Billie Holiday 的超级狂热粉丝。当我们问及此事时，他用了“狂热”这个词。所以当我们请他用他的号、他的小号演奏一曲时，他演奏了《Lover Man》。
Ira Glass：[MUSIC - "LOVER MAN" BY BILLIE HOLIDAY]
Ira Glass：[音乐 - BILLIE HOLIDAY 的《LOVER MAN》]
Ira Glass：That's pretty much all the time we have for this evening.
Ira Glass：今晚的时间差不多了。
Ira Glass：[FUNDING CREDITS]
Ira Glass：[赞助名单]
Ira Glass：This show was produced by Dolores Wilber, Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and myself. Contributing editors Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the west coast, Margy Rochlin on the east coast. I've got that backwards. Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the east coast. Margy Rochlin on the west. You see, you get so confused when you have two pieces of music running at the same time.
Ira Glass：本节目由 Dolores Wilber、Peter Clowney、Nancy Updike、Alix Spiegel 和我本人制作。贡献编辑 Paul Tough 和 Jack Hitt 在西海岸，Margy Rochlin 在东海岸。我弄反了。Paul Tough 和 Jack Hitt 在东海岸。Margy Rochlin 在西海岸。你看，当同时播放两段音乐时，你会变得非常困惑。
Ira Glass：[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
Ira Glass：[致谢]
Ira Glass：Torey Malatia has supported this show from the start. We'll be back next week, same time, we hope. From WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass.
Ira Glass：Torey Malatia 从一开始就支持这个节目。我们希望下周同一时间再见。我是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 的 Ira Glass。